film critics might provide an invaluable
filter between audiences and bad movies
but they don't always get it right in
the case of these secretly amazing
movies most reviewers majorly missed the
mark for those that put stock in the
Rotten Tomatoes score before ponying up
ticket fare these are the movies you
might have missed the first time around
and be warned there are spoilers ahead
the sell directed by Tarsem Singh the
cell is not a movie for everyone but
critics who accused the movie of being
shallow and derivative might have been a
bit too harsh in retrospect the film
tells the story of Catherine Dean a
child psychologist who uses some
impressive tech to enter the
subconscious of a comatose boy hoping to
bring him back into the real world
thanks to her unique set of skills she's
asked by an FBI agent to explore the
mind of an unconscious man who'd
imprisoned a girl in a bizarre deathtrap
before having a seizure now she only has
hours to live so Dean is tasked with
finding her whereabouts but this is
easier said than done since his
subconscious is a nightmare world of
torture devices horned monsters and
living dolls that resemble his victims
it's an S&M fever dream where corpses
are bathed in blood
horses are dissected with glass slides
and men have their intestines slowly
pulled from their bodies so the cell is
full of depravity but it's still pretty
gorgeous to look at thanks to some
horrific tributes to artists like Damien
Hirst odd Nerdrum and H R Giger and the
costume game is at its finest with
designer Eiko heo cos array of jumpsuits
demonic purple wings and sadistic sci-fi
masks better still the sets are
practical the performances are on point
and the result is something big bloody
and perversely beautiful of course they
didn't all get it wrong
Roger Ebert was one of the few critics
who actually liked it and in fact
declared it was one of the best films of
the year the hunted when it comes to
nail biters William Friedkin is one of
the best in the business
after all he's the guy who made films
like the French Connection and The
Exorcist in the hunted he gives us a
chase movie for the ages
even if critics weren't too impressed
the story follows a tired tracker named
LT Bonham who used to teach special ops
soldiers but unfortunately his training
was a little
good after seeing some pretty horrible
things overseas an old pupil has lost
his mind and now spends his time picking
off deer hunters so Bonham is brought in
to give his student one last lesson
Tommy Lee Jones is amazing as the weary
survivalist a man who knows what he has
to do but that doesn't mean he has to
enjoy it
sure that is as for Benicio del Toro
he's both scary and sympathetic as a man
who's seen and spilled far too much
blood Friedkin expertly follows these
two as they chase each other down and
when it comes to the final showdown
there are no showy ninja moves here it's
painful brutal and in-your-face which
pretty much sums up the entire feel of
this underrated thriller Constantine
when Constantine was released in 2005 it
had a devil of a time with moviegoers it
lost money at the domestic box-office
and critics did their best to exorcise
the film from theaters but those
reviewers must have been in league with
Lucifer because Constantine is one hell
of a movie granted it doesn't have much
in common with Hellblazer the comic it's
loosely based on but nevertheless it's
an amazingly fun film noir about a
chain-smoking cynic who Deportes demons
for entirely selfish reasons as a kid he
tried to take his own life and now he's
damned for all eternity so his plan is
to exorcise his way to heaven and he
finally gets a chance at saving his soul
when a cop asks him to take on a strange
case directed by Francis Lawrence
Constantine plunges our hero into a
world where otherworldly beings spend
their evenings at a supernatural Club
and heroes blast demons with crucifix
shotguns in this freaky film cats can
guide you to the underworld holy water
is stored in 5-gallon jugs and angels
dressed to the nines and killer
pinstripe suits John Constantine is one
of Reeves best performances the man is
playing a mash-up between Sam Spade and
neo from the matrix expertly blending a
snarky sense of humor detached detective
cool and a secret side of antihero
empathy then there's Tilda Swinton as an
incredibly suave Gabriel and Peter
Stormare as the sleaziest Satan of all
time with all that awesomeness it's
baffling the movie did so poorly but to
all the critics who've hated this film
Satine has a little message for you
[Music]
knowing there's no denying that Nicolas
Cage has had a checkered cinematic
career but faithful fans are rewarded
every so often with a legitimately great
movie like Joe annotation Bad Lieutenant
and knowing though almost every film
critic wishes the last movie would
disappear in an extinction-level event
knowing is genuinely thrilling and poses
some interesting philosophical questions
when it's not freaking you out it's
making you think which is why Roger
Ebert was the lone holdout who declared
it was one of the best science fiction
films he'd ever seen the plot revolves
around a rational professor played by
cage whose son discovers a 50-year old
document covered in numbers
despite his skepticism Koestler realizes
these numbers are a code for predicting
the dates and body counts of major
disasters and as he digs deeper into the
mystery he realizes something bad is
looming on the horizon with the
unsettling appearance of some
otherworldly strangers Koestler begins
questioning everything he's ever known
about the universe with director Alice
Proteus at the helm knowing is just
brimming with dread the same creeping
kind of fear you'd find in a movie like
sines plus the film grapples with
concepts like free will versus
predestination a deterministic universe
versus a random one you might not like
where the movie eventually sides but
it's a film that takes chances and
generates ideas that are well worth
exploring after the credits roll and you
have to do it you have to or I'll fire
you do you understand super before
directing guardians of the galaxy james
gunn put his stamp on the superhero
genre with super an upbeat version of
taxi driver where the supposed heroes
take out drug dealers with pipe bombs
and claws if you can stomach the gore
then you'll find yourself nervously
chuckling along with one of the best and
nastiest superhero satires the plot
follows a schlubby cook named Frank
whose wife has just left him for the
world's sleaziest drug dealer but after
receiving a vision from God one
involving razor blades and tentacles
Frank believes it's his divine mission
to become a superhero bike
crime and rescue his wife and
accompanying him on his quest is a comic
book nerd who has way too much fun
breaking legs and bashing heads
disguised as the Crimson bolt Frank uses
a pipe wrench to punish both child
molesters and people who cut in line the
violence is shockingly hard to watch and
as a result super feels like we're
watching a schizophrenic madman who's
building towards something terrible and
it's that over-the-top bloodshed that
angered so many critics but the violence
here is kind of the point
if superheroes existed in real life they
wouldn't be the most stable people on
the planet so super is a savage and
side-splitting response to every comic
book movie to ever come out of Hollywood
which is kind of ironic considering what
gun would later sign up to direct the
Crimson bolt the majestic in between
Stephen King adaptations Frank Darabont
decided to make a movie in the style of
Frank Capra the result was the majestic
a film so sweet and nostalgic that it's
shocking to think the same director
would later make the mist but while that
grisly creature feature is about as
pessimistic as movies get the majestic
believes in old-fashioned ideas like
right and wrong and freedom of speech
the story follows a blacklisted
screenwriter named Peter Appleton who
gets amnesia and winds up in a sleepy
little town where he's mistaken for a
long-lost World War 2 vet and since he
can't remember who he is or where he
came from
Peter accepts the story and bonds with
his new dad and a weary love interest
eventually Peters memories come flooding
back threatening his new existence and
things get even more complicated when
he's called upon to testify before the
house on American Activities Committee
but Peter rises to the occasion and
delivers a rousing speech in defense of
the right to say and believe whatever
you want Jim Carrey is on top of his
game here delivering a dramatic
performance that's right up there with
his roles in The Truman Show and Eternal
Sunshine of the spotless mind and the
majestic is an inspiring little film the
kind we hardly see anymore
vanilla sky' the world of vanilla sky is
filled with Monet's sunsets and Bob
Dylan streets but that doesn't mean
you'd want to live there why not well
it's also a world of crazy stalkers
creepy face masks and a dreadful feeling
that something awful is waiting in the
dark based on the 1998 Spanish film open
your eyes
Cameron Crowe's fifth feature marks the
spot where many believe he started
losing his touch despite its reputation
this Tom Cruise film is a massive mind
bender with more layers than inception
more twists than momentum and cruises
really earning his paycheck here is
David Aames an ultra rich playboy who
has his life ripped apart and then
starts losing his mind
maybe the superstar really sells David's
growing fear and paranoia and his
relationships with the women of the film
are masterfully crafted highlighting two
very different sides of the same man the
movie is also filled with some pretty
horrific images and some genuinely
disturbing moments from bizarre bedroom
body swaps to grotesque shots of Cruz's
face there's also a fantastic soundtrack
that features one of the most disturbing
uses of a Beach Boys song you'll ever
hear
The Book of Eli this movie starts off
with Denzel Washington shooting and
eating a feral house cat and it only
gets crazier from there set in a
post-apocalyptic world
The Book of Eli takes place at a time
when moist towelettes are used as
currency people pay to charge their
iPods and the local saloons make their
money selling water it's a dusty and
depressing realm where those who can
read hold all the power and faith is
more powerful than a loaded gun this
sci-fi Western follows Washington is Eli
a holy warrior wandering across what's
left of the United States accompanied by
a machete and mila kunis
Eli is carrying the last remaining copy
of the King James Bible and he hopes to
get the holy book to a safe place on the
coast unfortunately a small-town
dictator wants the book for himself
knowing it can help him establish his
evil empire only Eli isn't giving up the
good book so easily and instead of
turning the other cheek he's prepared to
take an eye-for-an-eye to make sure the
relic makes it safely across America in
addition to some masterful actions
the Book of Eli is a powerful commentary
on the power of religion but ultimately
it's a story that's also about the power
of the written word and how books can
shape entire civilizations thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]